let's read this first story some of you
may might be familiar with it because
you know it's going insanely viral
i tweeted about this it's from it's from
uh just the other day
at uh this story here is from the other
day where they actually came out the
cuban immigrants came out and rallied
against black lives matter who are
threatening them
but the tweet i put up has like 20 000
retweets so this is huge
so the initial story was that a group of
black lives matters act uh
black lives matter activists there you
go are going around downtown louisville
accusing these people
of being gentrifiers and because of that
they have to pay
hard cash a bunch of businesses agreed
to put up
this contract in their windows dear new
no not this one specifically there's
like this it might be this one but
there's other ones a list of demands
specifically
they want them to admit that their
gentrification is an oppressive system
targeting black folks for 400 years now
crete
and it's very creepy a bunch of these
businesses just said yes but one
business
said no we are not an enemy of the black
community
cubans rallied to support nulu
businesses take a look at this photo
all right maybe maybe the photos aren't
there we go it says we
left cuba because of socialism be
careful what you wish for
some of the demands requested by black
lives matter protesters included that
nulu businesses adequately represent
louisville's black population by having
a minimum
of 23 black staff now there's more to
that
they they don't write it out but no they
want front facing they they said
specifically that if someone walks in
they want front-facing staff so you'll
see who's working there
they said they want a purchasing minimum
of 23 percent
inventory from black retailers or
donating 1.5 percent of net sales to a
local black non-profit
or organization and requiring diversity
and inclusion training for all staff
members
on a bi-annual basis my goodness yeah
you know what's crazy about it
they're going to a cuban immigrants
restaurant he's got i think he's got two
restaurants now
it's called like the olay restaurant
group i think i think it is one of them
is called la boraguida de mima and
there's another one i'm not entirely
sure
what do you think they said some of
these activists said
when this cuban immigrant came out and
said
i will not stand for these mafia tactics
white supremacists
they called him they called him a
supremacist okay they said that he was
proving that he believes in his
supremacy
they couldn't call him a white
supremacist because he's a cuban
immigrant right
but they still tried and they called him
uh racist
and they said he thinks black lives
don't matter
he said that or they they're putting
that in his mouth no he definitely did
not say that right he said he stands
with the community he's you know he
stands with all people
he's got you know his family he's got
black family he's got a gay son he
absolutely believes in you know in
in social justice and civil rights yeah
but the only thing they can do
is that's the only weapon they have
there was there's a tweet going around
saying that the left is really good at
semantics
they changed the definition of words and
they
name themselves things that make it
really hard to argue against
for dumb people like black lives matter
if you oppose this group of people
threatening small businesses and
demanding
money otherwise they have a list of
repercussions for non-compliance
then you must not think black lives
matter don
uh uh don jr donald trump jr
retweeted your tweet just saying simply
that's extortion
and he was correct so literally what
this is they're extorting businesses
for money and you know how much i'd be
willing to bet the cops aren't going to
do anything about it
as we've seen with the expansion of
morality policing the mayor of
louisville is now saying that he wants
he thinks they should declare public uh
racism a public health crisis
well if that's true you can't go go
around arresting the people who are
going to solve that problem now can you
yeah and that's that's that's the trick
that's the lie so you got antifa
but that just means anti-fascist while
they go around giving explosives to
people to you know start fires blow
things up and
beat people if you say anything bad
about them
you're pro-fascist so there's a fake
tweet going around
they do this all the time one of the
biggest one of the biggest problems we
have right now with the left
using memes for news is that a good
portion of them are just fake
yep one of them was a group saying it
was uh it was the lapd i think a fake
tweet saying we oppose antifa and always
will we are exactly the opposite of
whatever antifa is
and so i read that knowing what antifa
is and i'm like oh so they're like
libertarian you know anarcho-capitalists
yeah no but because antifa thinks
you know from their perspective antifa
just means opposed to fascism that means
the lapd was
admitting they were fascists when in
reality the tweet was entirely fake
there's a there's a a thread from zach
goldberg
going through a bunch of data points and
one of them is that the left is
substantially
uh more likely to have been diagnosed
with mental health issues
for sure who is that zach i i don't i
don't exactly know do you know what his
title is he's like a researcher i think
yeah he is he researches i think social
justice i'll come up
is this like a government position or no
no no i don't think so no
general academia yeah is that what is he
social scientist yeah hold on let me
check
let's get let's let's he might just be a
random dude on twitter who's pulling
data from other social scientists hold
on i'll read it here i need i need the
receipts yeah all right he's a phd
student slash wokeness studies caller
researching the great awokening
okay i don't know what school he's at
though so yeah he's a he's a student
he's showing data from various uh charts
and he's citing
all of them but but i say i'm crediting
him for putting a thread together okay
and one of them shows that the further
left you go the more likely you are to
have been diagnosed with a mental
illness
and interestingly the far right is more
likely to have been diagnosed with a
mental illness
than conservatives so i i think they
call it like strong conservative or
something
okay meaning that there is a point where
it's like you go off into the deep end
but one of the things he also pointed
out was that the left is has a really
a much higher index of depression and
once you go towards the right depression
goes away
like happiness and general life
satisfaction goes way up
which makes me start to think something
about what we see with like what black
lives matter is doing
with what antifa does and how they name
their groups and then get away with this
stuff
i see from so many people we mention
this that they just screenshot
facebook posts they'll screenshot tweets
and that's their news and they'll share
these things
and i've like i can't tell you how many
times i've seen a bunch of these posts
where they're like
if you're upset that someone's getting
six hundred dollars
a week in unemployment then maybe you
know uh
these companies should be paying them
more and i'm like
okay the unemployment was a 100 percent
guarantee
plus 600 so no matter how much they were
making they were still getting more
money
yeah and so i've gone probably through
like 50 posts where i see these pop up
and i just like type it really quick
like here's
here's the thing here's the thing here's
the thing here's the thing but it's all
they keep doing to share this
information
i think what we're seeing is not that
liberals or leftists are more likely
mentally ill
it's that mentally ill people are more
likely to be leftist
why because they believe fake news they
believe these fake memes these fake
tweets these fake posts
and then you end up with moderates and
conservatives and non-mentally ill
liberals who all fall under one tent
saying like
we oppose this kind of behavior yeah but
if you get
a group that says you know their name is
black lives matter
and a regular person can understand the
distinction between
that doesn't literally mean they think
that especially when there have been
several people have lost their lives who
have been black during the riots and
they they said nothing about it
or that anti-fun literally you know just
because you call yourself the good guys
doesn't mean you're the good guys
whether you're a liberal or moderate or
conservative you can understand those
concepts
if you're not all with it you probably
can't and you get your information from
memes
and if it's if it's beyond just like a
diagnosed mental illness and it's
literally somebody who's just like
like a bunch of low iq people then
they're not going to be able to sort
through this stuff
and they're just going to be forming
angry mobs which is literally what
they're doing yeah
and then when a group goes around
threatening businesses
well no one stops them because the angry
mob is loud
yeah and they thrive as victims the
whole victimhood thing is
is rampant on the on the far left you
know they really
thrive in in being victims together i
mean
everything they're talking about is
we're victims we're victims we're
victims
and that's it basically if you look at
everything they say that's
that's the root they're all victims
that's they're all being oppressed
i think i think a lot of them know that
they're lying about being victims okay
and i think it's like narcissistic
personality disorder
borderline you know historic all of this
like really
just aggressive and angry and so they're
going around and threatening people with
the weapon they've been handed
victimhood yep so they see it it's like
a clear path
hey man i'll go to this business and
i'll walk up and i'll say here's my
demands you're gonna pay up or no and
then when they say no
smash some of their property up and say
we'll be back so so these are the
i read the demands already i think
there's a look at this i'm not going to
read this this is this is the
nulu business owners representation
contract
i'm not going to read it but i'm almost
i almost have to so you can so
so people can hear what it is but i
don't want to say these words i'll read
the first part i as a business owner
in the gentrified nulu business district
understand that gentrification targets
poor and disadvantaged communities of
color
and as such i acknowledge that the
original residence
here we go my my business has played a
part in this that the community members
were replaced
that many of the original residents were
repatriated i am therefore committing to
to you know fix things and then they say
to correct this lack of representation i
commit
to increasing black representation in my
business operations
and this shall include this is where
they say you know staff and management
positions you know
for black employees buying from black
vendors or giving
1.5 percent of our monthly annual
profits
23 of black businesses and board
membership in the new loop business
association
here's my favorite uh here's my favorite
part they mention uh
i can't search for this one of the
things they say is that you have to
submit
that we we demand you submit to a
voluntary audit yes
well that's not that's not voluntary
you're writing it
we demand you submit to a voluntary
you know uh where is it where is it
whatever here's uh it's
it's in here somewhere but it's it's
this is a photo so i can't actually
do a search for it but here check this
out repercussions of non-compliance
reduction in racial index score bias
report to the better business bureau
i don't think these people realize that
that's like telling someone you're going
to
complain to google i mean like they want
to speak to the manager
the better business bureau is like they
don't do anything
it's just like it's like yelp it's like
yelp before the internet right
so it's like i'm gonna call the better
business bureau and people like i don't
care okay karen yeah exactly
social media blast notification via all
social media platforms of non-compliance
boycott public boycott coordinated
through social media and mail
announcements
of your nulu establishment and any other
business ventures owned by you
protest visible media covered
demonstration sitting outside your
establishment
invasive reclamation placement of booths
and tables outside your establishment
where competing black proprietors will
offer items comparable
to those offered by you wow that sounds
an awful lot like extortion tim
it does the only thing is that the
demands are more of an
ideological bent so it's like
what would it be called i guess it's
still extortion like what would it be
called like a bunch of mormons walked
around
and they like went to business of
business but instead of being polite and
happy with smiles on their face
they had like bats and they were like
give donate to the church or else
that'd still be extortion extortion yeah
yeah it's like a sharia patrol
yeah morality policing literally yeah so
we were talking the other day and i was
like
i said the police will come to your
house and knock on the door so you can't
play rat music anymore yeah
it was a bit of an exaggeration but this
is basically it
they're going to so not necessarily the
residential houses yet they've done that
to politicians
we'll see if they start going to regular
people which they probably will in my
opinion soon
they're going to businesses now and
saying here's what you must do
to be in the good graces of the movement
and they want you to admit this is crazy
i blank see and support the black
community as a business owner dedicate
my time i pledge therefore blah blah
blah
you got to put your name you got to put
your business address and sign an
apology
acknowledging the faults of your
privilege you have to submit
we demand you submit to a voluntary
audit
i wonder if that i want i want to find
that but anyway
this is what they're demanding of people
in which case
what is this mafia yeah that's what i
was thinking
yeah so now here's what i don't think
the police will do anything about it
you can have every everybody in the
world tweet about it but we've already
seen
i i i do not see the police crossing
you know these activists or extremists
or whatever you want to call it mafiosos
they're just going to keep doing what
they're doing no one's going to stop
them
but there are people who are starting to
speak up so to be fair this guy in
louisville at this restaurant
is you know standing up pushing back and
saying no
yep now they have what is this the level
of representation shall be achieved by
august 17th 2020
with incremental increases of five
percent in each six-month period
well there you go this is what we can
expect to happen
and now when when you look at how the
press handles this kind of stuff this is
why i'm not confident
that we're going to see de-escalation i
don't know if you saw what happened with
the
nba dude what was his name jonathan
isaacs yeah
he yeah it's terrible what they're what
i mean the
the democrats are are and the crazy left
are basically
being like good good riddance he got
hurt well so
he's he's the guy who stood for the
national anthem and even his teammates
seem to be supporting him like let him
doing his thing and then he tore his acl
which was already weakened he had an a
knee brace on
and then he goes for a jump shot i guess
or something or a dunk i don't know
i'm not a basketball kind of guy uh but
he falls he falls down yeah and now
they're like
irony they're laughing ha ha he stood
for the national anthem stuff like that
but when it happens you can see the
other people wearing the black lives
matter
sweaters they you know they run in and
they're like concerned about them
i think that that to me was was like you
know a good sign that even these dudes
who are
you know clearly doing two different
kind of movements or whatever still
recognize their friends and all that
but based on how we've seen the
treatment of herman cain
when he passed versus john lewis when
you see what happens to this nba player
the media like listen
the courier journal of course is talking
about the story there's protests going
on it's local news
did cnn cover it new york times
washington post
vox no they don't want they don't want
to show people standing up against this
they don't want to show them extorting
people or extorting people right both
you know yep you hear what happened in
rockford illinois no it happened so
there was a back the blue
protest um just a bunch of people and i
guess
at the very the tail end there was like
four or five uh
anti back the blue you know uh black
lives matter
yelling black lives matter adam and then
they got violent
and they sent swot in there and took
them out
the the the far leftists or what the far
left us
they arrested each one of them oh wow
like so we're you know for each each of
these things
like this isn't on that's also not on
the news you know we're seeing these
specific examples of like like this i
mean this isn't even being on the news
you know but morality policing is sure
it's happening
but at the same time i'm seeing plenty
of other instances where
these cops are like we're not going to
take this this is this is ridiculous
we're not the mask police we're you know
you
you get violent in our town we're gonna
arrest you and yeah you're gonna go to
prison and that's what happened well
let's see if louisville does it i mean
the mayor is
clearly supporting this weird
intersectional identity
stuff but you know to be fair too i want
to make sure we clarify when they say
the media won't cover it
it typically refers to national level
media like
brian stelter on cnn goes on his show
and he goes and there it is
more proof of dictator donald trump or
some other stupid nonsense
because trump said some because trump
tweeted about delaying the election
question mark
and i tweeted him like trump tweeted the
the
the governor of new jersey had small
business owners arrested
yeah for trying to open their their gym
in this in a sleepy suburb
right so you want to talk to me about
who's a dictator who's a fascist
whatever
it's it's it's in it's absolutely insane
man and then we got
uh black lives mafia over here
the black lives matter yeah you know
louisville
what how is this not news how are people
not talking about this i've heard stuff
like this has happened in other places
i just couldn't find any confirmation
yeah it's crazy because
that's a big issue are people actually
going to cover this and the courier
journal i believe is part of usa today
but it's not for it it reaches the
national level because i
tweet about it so it's it's look when i
posted this story the first time
i didn't think i'd get that many
retreats i got like 20 000 yeah
and and i was like whoa i don't and now
all of a sudden we're starting to see
it's conservative outlets conservative
commentary starting to cover this
of course but the mainstream large news
outlets
have been totally co-opted by the far
left so this is the important thing to
realize when people talk about the
mainstream media is that
there's clearly left-wing media there's
clearly right-wing media
and then there's establishment corporate
media
that is dominated entirely by far left
ideology or at least
bends the knee to it which is going to
make things really really interesting as
we move now into
an election thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast we do
the show live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next
episode